um's and ours are quite often thought of
as errors that you want to get rid of
they're very commonly littered through
our talk and it's quite difficult to
totally erase them but what they're
doing is quite specific things so
sometimes they're doing i'm thinking i'm
searching for a word sometimes they are
showing difficulty in putting this thing
together they're showing an orientation
to delicacy they're doing lots of
different things in talk
what's your problem with asking people
how are you
our problem with people how they are but
it is a very interesting thing to
examine as it unfolds in real
conversations in real time in different
settings
why
so
hi how are you fine how are you is a
really common way in which conversation
starts it's a kind of no
problem very mundane routine way in
which conversations typically start
between people who know each other
fairly well
um
and those how we use can sound like
they're just fiddler talk that they're
not really doing anything very much that
people kind of lie in response they say
fine how are you not not you know my
life is horrendous they don't do it at
that point in the conversation
and so the fact is when you see loads of
those conversations starting in that way
it can just look like nothing special is
happening but once you start to contrast
those with other kinds of conversations
and the very start of them you can start
to see that that apparently pointless
filler talk is actually
telling you a lot about the kind of
interaction this is that's about to
happen so for example how do you convey
i'm in a rush something's an emergency
you stop people doing those how are yous
and you say immediately oh did i just
need to check did you leave the oven on
um i've got some nice examples where
people immediately start a conversation
not with hi how you but chris
liz
what what's the deal and you can
immediately see hey there's no how are
you they're about to have a huge
argument um and then i've got an amazing
example where um a woman calls nine nine
nine
um
and in order to convey to the the
dispatcher
somehow my life is in danger
but i need you to hear us hear that i'm
talking to if i i need the person who
might be actually threatening my life in
the house to stop to sort of hear oh
they're talking to a friend then you do
those you do those how are you and you
hope that the person on the other end of
the phone kind of catches on which they
do pretty quickly to oh this person is
pretending to have a conversation with a
friend by doing that thing that always
happens at the start of a call which is
quite amazing to see how calls that go
to 999 are not
somebody asking how are you and taking
the time with stuff
exactly yeah so i've got some amazing
data in which people are phoning up um
having to convey to the person that
they're talking to i'm i'm in danger but
they can't use those words because the
person or the situation that they are in
danger from is is there as well um so
how does that happen without using any
of the words people say things like
i'd like to order a pizza for delivery
how does the call taker here that as a
genuine request for help especially
since actually one of the tasks that the
said the police um call takers have to
do is figure out um
from all the all of the potential
nuisance schools that they actually do
get that do sound a bit like that how do
you figure that out but they can figure
it out pretty quickly
what is a better
question to ask somebody than hi how are
you
it depends what you what you want to do
so i this this it's not that it's a bad
question it's just that if it's there at
the start of a conversation then
probably it means that there's nothing
urgent nothing pressing nothing
no conflict about to happen it can also
be exploited by people so i've also
studied cold call sales where you can
see people saying things like hi how are
you
and and because
generally we can recognize someone's
voice when they do that kind of thing if
you don't recognize the voice you're
immediately on your guard because you're
like i don't recognize the voice even
from the start of this conversation and
so then what happens is that you don't
get fine how are you you might get fine
and then nothing
and if a sales person's any good they're
hearing oh this person doesn't want to
do small talk with me and they just cut
to the chase whereas i've got some
really cringe-worthy calls where people
still say
oh
and how's the weather and you're like
this person's going uh
listen to me i don't really want to have
this conversation with you so the how
the presence or not of how we use
are just very interesting at the start
right from the opening sort of few
seconds of a conversation you can tell a
lot have you ever looked at those
pre-recorded sales calls where it's hi
how are you silence
yes
that sort of they've obviously tried to
create a single-sided conversation with
sufficient breaks in between as to hook
someone in i can't believe that that's
ever worked
i can't believe it either because people
are really quick at figuring out that
this isn't a
human voice at the right pace at the
right pitch
even voices that are um
you know generated through some kind of
com algorithm or that or they're just or
actors are used to kind of put into some
kind of chat bot you can tell pretty
quickly um i didn't if there's a really
nice um
case called lenny the chat lenny the
chat bot um and lenny the chatbot um was
developed by somebody who basically
wanted to stop or just trap cold callers
to his home um
on a loop of their own kind of making so
so someone would phone the house and
lenny the chatbot would answer and lenny
the chatbot didn't have any kind of
algorithms or anything it was just
something like 16 phrases pre-recorded
and then shuffled and it sounded like
the voice of an elderly australian man
and so the person the cold caller did
think that they were talking to an
elderly australian man and they tried to
make sense of what this guy was saying
to them and so you know how long could
lenny the chatbot keep someone in a
conversation so that was that was very
nice and people can go and there's
endless recordings on on youtube you can
go and see how lenny manages to keep
people on on the line and people are
trying to get out but they're like oh i
can't really leave him now because he's
he sounds just like this old gentleman
and
yeah it seems like there's a particular
satisfaction on the internet for
watching scammers not saying that cold
calling is the same as scamming but some
people put it into a similar bucket
there's entire youtube is dedicated to
um
really sophisticated computer white hat
hackers that reverse the scammer cold
calls and they tell them stuff like i
know the address of the
um building that they're calling from
where they are and they sometimes do
other stuff to them play around with
their computer so that's it doesn't
surprise me that lenny the chatbot is
he's like the uh nerfed version he's
like the kiddies version of that so
given the fact that you do uh
conversational analysis for a living
just how much are humans pushed and
pulled around by language
a lot um which makes it sound
bad in a way like we're kind of
manipulating each other all the time but
everything gets done really through
interaction um even if we're not just
talking about words we're talking about
gestures and gays and
um all the embodied things that go along
with with words
and it's the thing that kind of drives
everything we we ask we invite we offer
we
get help we we do a lot of things in
everyday social life and our workplace
lives through social interaction and
without being aware sometimes and but
also of course sometimes really being
aware if you have that bristle bristly
feeling that someone's doing something
that you're finding difficult but you
can't pin it down sometimes they're the
kinds of things that for me as a
conversation analyst i can transcribe
and try to unpack
what it feels like when you're really
pushing for service when you like for
example i've studied people calling
their gp receptions um and what does it
feel like when you when somehow you're
not being offered things that is
probably the person's job to offer you
that thing what what does and if we
could we all feel that sense of like god
i feel like a burden i feel like i'm
really pushing you to
to give me some service and you can sort
of start to unpack that so a really nice
example is going into a cafe
uh getting your coffee or your tea
and saying do you have wi-fi
yes we do
so
uh can customers use it yes they can
this is this is real this is a field
note sort of scribble down hastily after
going into a cafe
um
and then eventually the the cafe very
sort of you know
cool cafe staff owner just sort of
points at the code which is painted in
this very arty hipster way right that's
like 12 foot high in the wall and you
get the code and so you really feel like
god i really had to drag that out of you
as though somehow you didn't understand
that you have wi-fi wasn't a request
for the code as well as it's not just a
yes no question whereas you know the the
much nicer experience which is also real
also scribbled down as a field note was
going into cafe as your tea comes across
the desk the cafe uh staff member says
oh by the way if you need the wi-fi
here's the code and what's so nice about
that is you feel really great about that
person the cafe and it didn't involve
things like hey what's your name
it didn't involve all of those more
scripted sounding things that seem to
have found their way into some types of
service encounter it's actually about
maybe you need this thing
and here it is you don't even have to
ask for it
it's cutting off at the knees as well
the amount of back and forth that's
needed between the person that's serving
presuming that they need to be efficient
and not waste their time having a
five-minute conversation about the wi-fi
code just exactly presuming that look if
you need the code it's up on it's 12
feet on the wall painted on a piece of
driftwood or whatever um that
that helps yeah another thing as well
i've noticed it seems like
brevity or at least um appreciating
people's time especially in the modern
world because everyone's so distracted
by the devices that their time to
actually do the things that they need to
do now has become completely condensed
down
um i think that just trying to do things
in the minimum
uh amount of time for instance if if
you're doing outreach to people my
advice has always been that the message
should be readable within the space of
about 20 seconds especially if the
person that you're trying to reach out
to is someone that's of high repute
right like you
they are very very busy and if you send
them a huge essay that they've got to go
through i think that your chances tend
to decrease and that's kind of the same
for even my mum my mom's a perfectly
pleasant person but she doesn't want to
spend forever talking to the checkout
cashier at the local shop
yeah
yeah i think the cafe example that i
just gave is a nice
example of how quickly you can make
someone feel a bit warm towards you
whilst i'm getting getting needs
potential needs met but it's very very
short and very very efficient
um i've also done some work when people
are phoning the vet um so this is a nice
example of actually
listening for what people want in this
moment as well and whether or not you're
able to do that so
case one someone phones up and says how
much does it cost to get injections done
from a new puppy
and the vet receptionist trying to build
rapport or i don't know you know
just sound lovely on the phone he's like
oh what's your puppy called and there's
this little delay and in my world delays
of like 0.7 seconds is quite large and
you might get victor
now that's someone who doesn't want to
have a long conversation about the new
puppy but but the call taker isn't
really she's just going for it anyway oh
and is it your first puppy
yeah
like you shouldn't be able to hear by
now they just want the price and in fact
in this particular call it's almost like
the sort of star wars credit that this
this sales well it's not even a sales
person the receptionist goes on and on
and on what we can do for you is and and
in the end it's you know it's going
nowhere whereas actually you know maybe
at that point where you say oh what's
your book called and the person's like
oh well you know we some people are
dying to talk about their new puppy so
can you be nimble enough and listen
enough to actually think right this is
someone to do that with because they
dying to do it this is someone who just
wants the information
it's interesting thinking about the fact
that people's words are one of the most
um
[Music]
direct insights that we have into their
nature as a person so yeah actions are
important or whatever you know like
someone's saying uh i hope the funeral
was good
whilst not being there isn't quite the
same but
someone's words and the way that they
put them across to you when we're
talking about someone and saying that
they're
rude or abrupt or nice or kind or caring
or whatever that
forms a massive amount of our
interpretation of that person and their
personality overall
yeah absolutely so i have this thing
it's not a serious thing um i should say
but i called like the conversation
analytic personality diagnostic which is
not a serious personality tool but the
point is that when you're in a an
interaction a conversation with somebody
you don't sort of give them a question
there check what kind of personality
they are on some scale if you believe in
that kind of thing
and then on the basis of what they score
they're an extrovert an introvert
whatever they are you then take the next
turn you have to be much faster than
that all the time and so
exactly that you're you're kind of on
what basis would you say someone is rude
or or they seem warm or they will help
you know
it's basically what they do and of
course a lot of what you do is what you
say so we do have this this sense of you
know you can talk the talk but can you
walk the walk and actions speak louder
than words but in my world again
you know a lot of what we do is what we
say they're the same sorts of things so
so what is being offensive a lot of the
time it's not
you know you don't do being offensive by
punching somebody i mean that would be
offensive but you'd be offensive through
your words um so what you do is it is
basically what a lot of people are using
almost all the time to decide what kind
of person you are
i like that reversal of the
of the age-old wisdom of it's not about
what you say it's about what you do but
yeah you're right for the most part
people aren't doing things they're
saying things and if the broadest area
under the curve is people just talking
about stuff
making sure that you talk about things
in an appropriate manner to get the kind
of response that you're looking for and
to have the sort of impact that you hope
for is really really important
yeah absolutely yeah so so
um how do you
for example i've got this this one of my
categories is the idea of the first
mover um so parents can often be first
movers which and by that i just mean
that
they take a problematic first turn and
and then you can get trapped immediately
in a conflict so things like
i don't really like that jumper it's
like
wow you know if i said that to you mum
dad you'd be like oh i'm so offended you
know and you and if you call them out in
it they're like oh i was just joking so
so you know people can be quite
challenging in their opening gambits and
then somehow if you call them out on it
you're the problem by being offended
rather than the person actually being
offensive in the first in the first
instance um so again you know
lots of examples of that in email as
well you know people will write you an
email
that somehow is you immediately feel
annoyed but you can't say anything
because
strangely enough the sort of constraints
around the way we interact with each
other mean that it's actually quite hard
to to just maybe
be as direct back you have to let we let
a lot of things slide don't we all you
know because otherwise
you just be angry all the time is there
something about that is there something
about the convention that when somebody
sort of is that first mover and maybe
decides to take a left turn out of the
conversation to say something that's a
bit that's got a bit of snidey top spin
there is something that when you break
the fourth wall you go hang on a second
that's that's a bit
that's a bit unfair isn't it and if
especially if you do it in a group and
there's other people listening as well
it's like the record needle scratching
and everyone was like
yeah in a way that the first mover being
a dick
didn't
that's so strange
yeah i mean people's
you know some people's entitlement to
take that first turn
on the basis that quite often people
won't
won't challenge them on it um
because it's difficult too it's really
difficult too so
everything from
um so again going back to the patients
calling their doctors those kinds of
conversations right sometimes at the end
of those conversations they end in a
very orderly way so in that hi how are
you fine how are you the ends of
conversations
when somebody is calling up as a service
user
the service provider provides a service
and then the service user it's up to the
service user to kind of say right this
is over and they say thanks or thanks
very much and then the service provider
will say thanks and then bye bye so it
goes thanks thanks bye bye
really really really commonly now in my
lots of analysis of all of these
patients calling their gps occasionally
what will happen
is that the
the service provider the receptionist
will have you know said something or
other and said you know your
prescription will be here and then
they'll say
thanks and they are trying to end the
call but it's not really their place to
go first and what happens very typically
after that is then the patient has to
sort of jump back into the conversation
and say oh but so who am i seeing so so
when and so you've got the burden on the
patient to get maybe the confirmation
that they were after but also push past
the receptionist trying to end the call
and basically what you see in in those
moments is just the just the pain
the painfulness of withholding a thank
you so the next time you're unhappy on
the telephone call try not saying thank
you at the end try try to not say thank
you first and then if when the reception
is still the service provider says
thanks to end the call try not saying
thank you you'll feel really horrible so
from from from that sense of like it's
very difficult to just not say thank you
at the end of a call all the way through
to how do you
how do you be an ally how do you speak
up if someone is being sexist racist
whatever the ism prejudice might be
and one of one of the interesting things
again i've done a lot of work on what
counts as an ism which is different for
different people and then what do you do
in response and of course people will
say what they would say in response to
somebody being racist in a room
but actually there's a whole range of
things that people do and some of them
are very tiny so some of them are things
like
if you're in a meeting and someone says
something
that is problematic in whatever way you
may not say anything in that room
because you you're not the chair you
your junior you can't it's difficult but
what you might do is actually just look
at for a moment at someone catch the eye
of someone else in the room and know
that they're seeing things in the same
way that you are so maybe you deal with
it later
um so so all the way through to doing a
direct challenge and then seeing that
ripple effect into the interaction
um and actually one of them one of the
most effective things that you can do
when somebody is being problematic in
lots of different ways is to just wait
because actually people will quite often
back off their own thing or they'll
they'll do what we call self-repair
they'll they'll sort of notice that
people haven't immediately come back
with it
and they'll inspect their own thing and
say oh but i didn't mean x or of course
i didn't mean that other thing so and
then
again you know every every single time
in conversation you're deciding to say
something or not say something say
something or not say something and it's
running fast you know the conversation's
running really quickly
so it's it's
one of the things that is really i think
useful for people and i quite often use
these sorts of materials in workshops is
actually see these sequences unfold
where someone said something everyone in
the room is saying oh my god i can't
believe they said that and this is what
i would do and then you see how it
actually unfolds and sometimes there's
quite a gap between what people imagine
they would do
and what actually happens
what are the interesting insights that
you've learned around silences and stuff
in conversations that's something that
on the podcast i had to get used to very
early on that there was a famous clip
actually i'm not sure whether you saw it
but you would you'd be fascinated you
can go back and watch it elon musk went
on lex friedman's podcast about six
months ago and a clip went round the
internet and did about a million plays
and it was a 31 second pause
after lex asked a question and before
elon did and after a while it becomes
comical they just sat in silence but
elon he's asked how long is it going to
be until we get to mars and elon sits
and
thinks and thinks and thinks and thinks
but that ability to sit with silence is
something that new podcasters really
struggle with and generally people
overall do so why is silence so
uncomfortable and what are some of the
interesting things that you've learned
from studying silence in conversations
so my field of conversation analysis is
right from the start it's sort of been
you know running for 50 years of so the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
conversations in all settings you can
imagine have been
recorded transcribed and we use a very
technical system to transcribe which
will you know pinpoint exactly how long
any silence any gap or pause is
and turns those hi how are you fine how
are you you know you're looking at about
100 to 200 milliseconds so that that's
quite a pace of interaction
um one of the founders of the field um
said that a silence of one point naughts
you know like a complete a whole second
is is starting to be quite a delay and
you can even see that when um you know
so as soon as you see a conversation
where there's a two second delay or
three second delay they're quite big
delays now of course depending on
whether you are you can see each other
you're co-present or you're on the phone
or you're writing which is different on
something like you know whatsapp but
those silences can sometimes be clear
about what they're doing so silence
isn't typically an inert thing you can
show someone
that you're thinking like elon did yeah
and but even so you know there's a sort
of there's a there's a point in time
where that just gets too long and i
would say you know 31 seconds or
something is is a massive outlier for
interaction so
that the longest
silence that i have got in any of my
data is police interview with the
suspect it's 11.2 seconds
the police have asked a question that's
really difficult for the suspect to
answer because almost anything is going
to be incriminating and in the end after
11.2 seconds the suspect says
i really can't deal with that question
actually
and so they you know in the end it
doesn't work but
and it's interesting that you mentioned
this because just just today um i was
talking with a colleague about another
really famous clip that you can go and
look online which was charlie state
interviewing lady gaga
about
seven six or seven years ago and it's
something like um he's asking her about
trump and she says she won't talk about
it
and then there's this long silence and
it's very it's very awkward to look at
and what's quite interesting is
a a year later i happen to be doing a
talk and it happened to be the event was
sort of hosted by charlie state and he
asked the same question about these
silences and then he told this little
story that that silence was actually 16
seconds long and before they broadcast
it they cut it because it was so painful
for viewers they didn't want the viewers
to have to sit through 16 seconds worth
so those long silences are a real
breach and and i suppose the fact that
we see them as we can immediately pick
up on that being a breach of of the sort
of normal typical
pace at which interaction occurs
you know we wouldn't see it as a breach
if we didn't sort of tacitly know
somehow you know about
about a second is already getting quite
long so
six is huge and you know 11 is massive
and 31 is you know
that's a long long painful silence
why is it painful what is it about the
rhythm of conversation and the breaking
of that rhythm that makes us feel like
that
nails on chalkboard thing
i think it's it's
i mean i don't the the why is difficult
but what i can say is that
that what we see in interaction when we
record it and transcribe it is simply
that those lengths of delays don't
happen so they're not in our daily
experience so just for as a basic thing
we're not used to
regularly experiencing those length of
delays because they just don't really
happen
so it's like what's going on immediately
this is really strange it feels strange
because it is strange quite simply
empirically you know when you look at
the data it is just weird yeah and
unusual and the other thing is that we
you know we tend to
uh
want to fill silences as well so
we we we're constantly inspecting
everything that everyone says to us as
an analysis of what we did previously so
if i ask you a question and you don't
answer for 31 seconds i think i'm you're
starting to think do i need to re design
the question was the question not clear
because typically a silence you know it
will it will initiate what we call
repair of some kind so it might be that
i ask you a question there's a silence
and i immediately redesign the question
or i issue an invitation and there's a
silence and so i immediately say well
so concrete example you know you ask
someone do you want to come for dinner
friday there's a silence so we're so
tuned into it that we
immediately pick up that they're not
going to respond within those sort of
split seconds and we say or saturday so
we're very attuned to how our
interlocutors are responding to the
actions that we are producing as they
come out and that's why like you're
nodding as i'm saying these things so
you you know i almost don't have to
finish this you know where i'm going
with this action and that's how we're
able to actually be so fast and that
you know so you're we're preparing our
responses you know so that their
precision time within tenth of a second
how do we manage to do that
it's because
of the sort of familiarity with a lot of
actions that we're actually doing in our
interactions which makes anything a
delay
and you know a classic another one is
you know
saying i love you you know that you've
got to be like really rapidly coming
back
you know
is a problem
yeah another thing that you see amongst
and this is me reflecting on me a long
time ago uh new podcasters especially is
that they'll ask a question and then
they'll give the guest a menu of options
that they can choose from
so
liz you know why did you get into
studying conversational analysis was
this something that you did as a kid or
was you know was it and to me what i
used to feel was sort of this visceral
discomfort around asking a question and
not having the confidence that the
question was sufficiently interesting
that i could just sit and just let the
other person
marinade in the question because
sometimes it's a difficult question
sometimes it's maybe a question that
they don't often think about or haven't
heard before but then by giving the sort
of menu of options i start to lead them
towards
and it's a really dumb idea for
podcasters to do because what you're
doing is you're you're offering
especially if it's an open question
you're offering the guests the
opportunity to pick from every single
potential question on the planet and
then if you give them two options they
have to either
pick one or the other say why it's not
the first or the second one or
somehow break the convention that you've
already constrained over them and go
well actually it's neither and very
rarely will you ever hear someone say
it's neither most of the time the guest
unless they're super disagreeable is
just going to
kind of take one of your suggested
answers for them and then rework that
into what they would have said in any
case but it's
it's mostly in my experience it's mostly
about the comfort of question stop
silence
and
it's interesting that you raised that
because there are
you see that in particular settings
where
it's both surprising and really matters
and is consequential
so
if you've got a list of questions that
you're going to ask somebody
in some settings your list of questions
is quite formal it's a diagnostic
instrument for example or it's uh it's a
police interview or it's somehow a
regulated kind of conversation where
there's guidance and some standard
things it's a standardized survey you're
meant to ask the same question in the
same way
over and over again
what researchers in my field show is
that it's actually really difficult to
first of all ask a question that is even
an open you know a wh kind of open-ended
sort of question
or it or a yes no kind of question
um which again a bit like you know do
you have wi-fi that isn't a yes no
question that requires a bit more so so
open and you know this idea of open and
close is a little bit of a myth but just
sticking to this idea that you can just
let's say read out a list of questions
without embellishing them without going
um halfway through without tweaking them
slightly
and so
people are very surprised when they see
what they imagine is a standardized
instrument standardized experimental
instructions in a laboratory
standardized police interview whatever
it might be
and then
you just imagine that that's how they
are that's how they work then there is
the law there is a script there is a
list of questions but it's remarkable
how the reality of those interactions
just doesn't look like that and so you
can imagine situations where this is
becomes really problematic so if it's
for example i've done some research on
this with colleagues in norway we were
looking at how teachers
basically do oral communication
assessments and they're meant to ask a
question the same kinds of questions to
all the pupils but sometimes they do
exactly what you say they ask a multiple
unit question
and then the pupils like well which bit
of that shall i address typically you
address the last bit first and then you
may or may not go back to the first bit
but it's but it seems just quite
difficult to just stick with this one
question without doing a bit more work
it's the same in diagnosis so you know a
psychiatric consultation there's meant
to be a standardized question it'll get
a bit of embellishment not for what for
what reason it's there's some
interactional imperative that
makes us makes it very difficult to
sound like a form even if you're a
police officer in the situation where
the law says say it like this it doesn't
quite look like that
what are ums and ours and
uh your nose used for
ums and ours and your nose and okays
they're all different sorts of things
so they they're not interchangeable uh
in in in a conversation
um's and ours are quite often thought of
as
errors that you want to get rid of so
um
like that one now
they can but they can they can they're
very commonly littered through our our
talk and it's quite difficult to totally
erase them
and
but what they're doing is quite specific
things so sometimes they're doing
i'm thinking i'm searching for a word
sometimes they are
showing
difficulty in putting this thing
together they're showing an orientation
to delicacy
so they're doing lots of different
things
in in talk
people are critical of others who say
oman are
but when you see a transcript when
people see a conversation analyst
transcript for the first time they're
quite shocked at how messy it all looks
but that is how we talk
um so yeah
but they're but they're doing specific
things and i'll just say one thing about
um's and ours which is maybe interesting
i said talked a bit earlier about people
phoning the vet so i compared real pet
owners telephoning the vet with mystery
shoppers who don't really have a pet but
are phoning up vet practices to report
back and hug with the services
so
and you know these mystery shoppers they
have quite a lot of power in a way
because what they're doing is going back
to the organization to say how good
people are answering the phone
and so my question is how good is a
mystery shopper at passing as an as a
as a pet owner because no one's done
that research so we're just taking it
for granted that this mystery shopper
can compass as a
as a real pet owner and the thing is
from a distance they totally can but
when you start to look at lots of calls
you see how different they are so
a very gross difference is
real pet owners typically phone up to
make an appointment a mystery shopper
will phone to say how much is the cost
of the service and then when the
receptionist tries to give them some
help like you want me to book you in and
sort of help you navigate calendars the
mystery stop is like oh i might call
back later which is really weird and
you're thinking what what can they
possibly report back to the organization
they gave me a cost of something that
was it but
the um's and ours
are are so interesting in these in these
calls so
i'm gonna totally make a mess of even
saying this but i'll try and get it
right so
the mystery shopper will typically phone
up and say how much would it cost to get
a dog
vaccinated
a real caller will say how much would it
cost if they're asking about cost how
much i've got a new puppy how much would
it cost to get my dog vaccinated so they
don't say add dog they say my dog for a
start
but the mystery shopper might say how
much would it cost for a
uh sorry how much would it cost for a um
dog
to be vaccinated whereas the real caller
is more likely to say
how much would it cost for my dog to be
uh vaccinated so the ers are in
different places and what's that about i
mean i don't know i don't have enough
data to really address the question but
what it shows us is that the ums and
ours aren't randomly splattered
everywhere they are when you look at
enough of them they're doing particular
bits of work in particular ways
and it's quite fascinating if you're
someone like me to figure out what
that's doing i read a blog post not long
ago that was talking about the relative
interpretation of people who either used
silences or ums and filler words in
between on whether they were seen as
more or less intelligent
and i can't remember what the outcomes
of that study were do you have you ever
looked at this stuff
i haven't seen that but i i i can
imagine that the outcome was that the
people who say oh man are judged to be
less intelligent because that would be
the stereotype but i can't remember i
feel like i feel like it wasn't quite as
simple as that i feel like the results
were
more along the lines of what you do
which is pretty much everything's
contextual it's more to do with the flow
of the conversation anyway because
somebody that's using silence is
actually showing that they have
confidence to be able to let that sit
and that they're maybe being more
considered with what it is that they say
so i guess it's it's much more colorful
speaking
of filler words
why is everybody saying the word like
i don't know it's the one this is come
on
this is you this is right in the middle
of your wheelhouse why why are we cursed
with this word
i haven't studied it but it is something
that maybe i should start analyzing i
mean obviously people put it in in place
of say
um or or or or an action so she was like
he was like and it was before a quote
before reported speech it can come
before a reported action so it's
definitely doing some kind of
preface to describing the words conduct
behavior of other people
um
i don't know why it's so common it's a
generational thing but um but like like
lots of words you know i i definitely
say stuff that my mum doesn't and
you know i i say stuff that my students
don't and we you know things just
sort of come in and out of
of common usage
and that's just language language is
alive it grows it changes uh one of my
favorite things to do is have a look at
uh if you just google any word
it will give you a it will give you a
dictionary definition but also give you
use over time so for example if you look
at marvelous you know marvelous i don't
know which way this is going to go on
your screen but you know marvellous has
dropped off a lot in usage but awesome
has increased you know and you can start
to see
the people who might be thinking oh we
need to rescue marvelous you know that's
a great word and and but then you know
people are saying awesome and that's
hard to resist so yeah language changes
all the time and i think the important
thing is to try not to put any kind of
value judgment on
this idea that saying like
has something to do with that person's
character because again as soon as you
start to look at transcripts of people
actually talking
politicians you know everybody you can
show a lot of mess and
repair error speech perturbations ums
and ours and everything in in pretty
much anyone's conversation
i saw a transcript that you've done i
think of boris johnson
trying to give a pretty short speech and
it just looks like someone's thrown
alphabet spaghetti down on a piece of
paper it's it's not very slick at all
you think this person has literally been
elected to the highest
position of power
below the queen
in the united kingdom and he we
basically can't speak when you read it
out
yeah absolutely and i mean there is some
of that is just kind of standard and
normal like i was saying you know we're
much messier it seems when you see it
all written down and transcribed
um but yeah
sometimes it can be interesting to
really try to be be precise about the
mess
especially when you know if someone's
judged to be a great orator for example
or they sort of pride themselves on
speaking latin and dropping that into an
interaction and then show actually is
quite messy
yeah but there's only so much of some
people's voices you can take
in your in your ear because you have to
go over you know it takes a long time to
do the transcription so yeah yes i bet
and
well i suppose some people kind of play
into it right so i've got a friend rory
sutherland who is kind of a big gruff
british man he talks like this and
everything's a bit [ __ ] isn't it uh and
the way that he speaks
i find incredibly charming he'll sort of
well you you know create and he'll
add in these elements but for him it's
part of i i find it completely part of
the charm that he'll
pontificate
with noise for a little bit and then
deliver some amazing insight and i think
that that goes back to what you were
saying before about the fact that it's
so contextual the fact is that how is
this person delivering it with
everything else as well and speaking of
that there's a common held belief that
some huge percentage of our
communication is non-verbal
is that true
so if we yeah this this is a great
communication myth very easily busted
so
if you look if you google this you'll
see lots of examples of a pie chart and
the pie chart will tell you that
communication is 93
non-verbal and 7 verbal
so if i now turned off the audio
this podcast would make sense still for
93 of the time we immediately know that
can't be true
but
and and you know
it's very easy to sort of make that myth
fall over so for example if if the
podcast you're just listening to it on
audio how come radio is so popular if 93
of communication is non-verbal how do we
ever speak in the dark how do you have a
conversation when someone's downstairs
and you're calling up and down so
obviously this doesn't really make sense
if you go to another country and it's a
different language you know like if you
go to france and you don't speak french
you should be able to get by 93 of the
time so this it just doesn't really make
any sense but it's so compelling and
people do love a good statistic and a
nice pie chart and they feel like wow
i've really learned this thing and it
definitely makes sense but one of the
even nicer things about that particular
communication myth is that the author of
some of the original studies albert
morabian
himself has tried to bust the myth and
sort of say how irritated he is by the
sort of
he calls them something like self-styled
communication consultant gurus who sort
of stick this on pie charts and it
wasn't what he found it was something
else it was more complicated whatev
whatever
um but
i mean i've been in lots of events you
know where people are talking about this
stuff and they just trot it out and
again almost always i just don't say
anything because it's just it seems
petty to say this is rubbish but okay
then or you just have to let it go but
it but it's clearly wrong you only have
to think about it for like two seconds
to think yeah that can't be right
is body language
stuff bollocks as well then if i look up
into the right if i cross my arms if i
start mirroring your posture and stuff
like that how much truthfulness is in
that
so
obviously our bodies our gestures our
gaze and all of those things are all
working in aggregate to get things done
so
if you know if somebody is you know goes
past in front of your camera and they
might do that that might mean you want a
drink and there's no words needed we
know what that means but of course you
can't just do that like i can't do that
to you now and like how you know how
you're going to get me that drink it's
not going to happen so
if you think about something like a
request
depending on
what you're asking for who you're asking
you're in your entitlement to ask for it
their obligation to fulfill the request
um how important it all is
we will design our requests differently
and depending on the sort of in the
resources that we have to interact we
will deploy them as well
but of course you know doing things with
our bodies and our heads and our eyes is
really important and
to give you one example of of this
totally silent second long interaction
it's coming back from scotland on the
train a few years ago
and
i got on edinburgh and the train was
semi-empty then i had a ticket
got on got my seat and then gradually
you know coming all the way back down to
the east midlands it gets busier and
busier and busier got rowdier i think
they've been football not sure but the
train got really busy really rowdy very
crowded
and a bunch of blokes got on they were
obviously quite drunk and didn't know
what their team would happen but you
know it was rowdy and it had that sense
of like not sure where this is going and
obviously
you know for me sitting there i'm just
thinking just reap about not don't make
eye contact just hope it'll all be fine
but there's a woman stood at the end of
the carriage so i'm sort of sat halfway
down the carriage and the woman at the
end of the carriage
and we just look at each other for a
split second well you know maybe a
second and in that moment we tell each
other
we're seeing the situation we'll just
keep an eye on each other
and
you know i don't know who she is never
saw her again nothing happened it was
all okay but in that moment you know
some you you're doing something and
that's just a look
but of course how do you turn a look
into a into a look you know you have to
even we we're even tacitly you know
we're not aware of it but we're
calibrating our gaze so carefully that
we know what our look is versus when
we're talking and we're you know looking
to the right lying looking to the left
not like whatever it might be but you
know those things i think generally
don't have much evidence behind them at
all because it's actually really
difficult to assess that kind of look to
the right look to the left is this lying
is this flir you know what what are
these things because they're almost
never studied in natural settings and
that is the sort of the usp of my field
we look at real interaction where the
stakes are real whatever they are for
people
in the wild not simulated we don't look
at interaction in the laboratory we
don't ask people about their
interactions and that's very important
to the kind of work that we do in
conversation analysis
i saw that a ton of psychological
studies have just been put close to the
chopping block uh
power poses uh nudging was in there as
well a bunch of stuff um that was really
really struggling to replicate and i
think that one of the big questions that
was being asked there was around the
fact that look in a naturalistic setting
this just
it's very very difficult for us to get
this but okay so how are you going to
study it if it study if it's outside of
the laboratory and is this you know
cultural conditioning masquerading as
human nature how do you separate out the
cultural conditioning from something
that's more inherent i mean that's
it's it is an interesting one i remember
seeing this meme ages ago that was um
the look that you give old people when
you walk past them on the street as a
teenager to let them know that you're
not a chav and it was the
that face it's not a smile it's sort of
down into the sides
sort of thinning of the lips and
widening of the face without opening the
mouth up and
i i haven't been able to stop thinking
about that meme i just must have seen it
two years ago because it's completely
true i have no idea there's no name for
what that
greeting emotion is
it's not a hello
it's it's actually something to do with
like a
i'm okay and you're okay
maybe i i don't know do you know the
thing that i mean do you know the
dynamic i'm talking about yeah
absolutely i i mean i'm i'm
probably phoneticians could give the
answer to this because they're very
interested in
somebody who studies the way speech is
produced including things like the diff
let's say the difference between going
yeah and yep
and something about the closing of the
yep
we all know when we've been yepped
rather than yet
so i think there is something about a
closed mouth
smile
it's like the most neutral but friendly
thing i'm not going to open my mouth i'm
not going to do anything i'm keeping my
mouth closed
yeah i think that there is something
in in
showing i'm doing nothing if you like
yes yeah very passive
yeah so
i have a colleague and she gets her
students to as a kind of experiment go
on to you know go somewhere on campus
and then do nothing how do you do
nothing in a way that doesn't attract
attention of course and you're not
allowed to look at your phone you know
how do you do it and
it's how do you how do you stand at the
bar
and do i am waiting to be served versus
i'm at the bar but i don't actually want
to be served yet because i'm waiting for
someone and we have really you know
loads of ways of doing nothing in an
innocent way
how do you how do you do nothing in an
innocent way on the street well we could
do it
so it's trying to it's the same sort of
thing how do you show somebody that
you're not threatening
and you know you've you've picked out
that meme and i think that's yeah spot
on
what about dating and first date
do's and don'ts what are some of the
biggest things that people should and
shouldn't do
um
i i did do some research 10 or so years
ago on speed dating it's my one and only
foray into it because i thought oh god i
don't want to be the professor of dating
actually
and the thing that i was particularly
interested in was this is this again
this was a this was before things like
first dates on the television which i've
never seen i keep thinking i should go
and look at those but you never know
what the raw data is like so
so i was looking at people on speed
dates they were in a particular age
bracket 30 to 45
and it was you know what do they what
seems to be
the components of a date that runs
smoothly i didn't know what happened you
know into the future of their lives
um and
some of those things are
you know quite obvious actually ask
questions that aren't weird questions
that aren't too intrusive that haven't
been learned from a little book you know
about you know ask them like
what's the most dramatic thing that's
ever happened to is your first question
because that would be a really
interesting topic actually some you know
you need to do those mundane things
first and just sort of just just
turn by turn feel your way into the
action into the interaction and just
take con that's what we're doing in
conversation we're constantly taking our
cues from the other person so it's a bit
like being that vet receptionist the one
who notices this one doesn't want to
talk about their dog versus this one
definitely does so all of those kinds of
things are
are the same
i think having a topic
um you know finding a topic that you can
expand for more than
two or three turns is important
i've just started to do some work on
first
dates on messenger and whatsapp you know
maybe the modern way to do it so i'm
looking at things like
rapid rapid rapid message message
message silence
you know so you so you can see
and i've got i've got these people from
early dating all the way through to like
the development of when they're an item
and then a bit more and you can see some
painful stuff like yeah message message
message message
you know all going smoothly and then
there'll be a delay and then the first
person is like how long are they going
to wait before they try again to restart
the encounter and i don't know even just
reading these things that i've never met
the people it's just text messages but
you sort of feel feel the pain of the
person who's like they haven't said
anything shall i try again and
eventually you know you can't triple
text you can double text but you can't
triple text is that right i also had a
phd student a few years ago who
screenshotted screen recorded people
doing facebook messenger chat so we
could see what they were writing before
they sent it
and you know some of these conversations
were hilarious because you'd see someone
the cursor will be blinking there on on
the screen and they'd be typing x x x
blinker you know then delete
and then like maybe a sticky out tongue
emoji delete and then like what did they
end up sending and you know i'm thinking
what would that look like in in a real
conversation if it was face to face that
would be quite a strange kind of like
are we going for like cheek cheek what
are we doing in this way we're greeting
each other or signing off uh so yeah
it's but but what you see in though in
her particular uh work is
the same kind of things that you see in
in spoken interaction it's just that you
can't hide the fact that you are
starting it one way
and then deleting it and doing something
else whereas in fact our conversation is
full of
things like um
from my from the dating stuff that i
looked at there's these moments that
always happen which is about whether or
not the person's been married before so
this is this demographic 30 to 45.
and so um
one of the things that always comes up
either because people disclose it
tacitly like saying things like i was
divorced or i've got kids so they give
away some of their relationship history
but if they don't then it becomes a bit
of an elephant like like okay who's
am i gonna ask you what your
relationship history is how am i gonna
figure this out and what i found was
that
women want in these dates this is you
know 10 years ago as a particular cohort
women ask men so what's your
relationship history then they want to
know and men are accountable if they
can't say age whatever for you know 40
that they've had some kind of commitment
in the past whereas i have to say in my
small data set it didn't matter the
other way around so men didn't ask the
question and they didn't you know they
weren't bothered if a woman hadn't had
that kind of
demonstrable commitment previously but
i've got this this one case where the
the woman is is saying you know
so if you've got so you've got no ki any
kids like i probably can't say that
you've got no kids on the base of
everything you've told me so far which
sounds very sad and you see these little
little little corrections as the
question comes out so if you were in
writing them down you could it would
look like
so no kids then delete got any kids yes
yeah yeah yeah well i suppose
you wouldn't see the presumption and
then i suppose i should ask you this
even though i definitely know by now i
can tell you know whatever when you're
studying chats you're only studying what
people ended up pressing send on but
yeah the number of times that you go
back and forth and then you have to
think that there's one layer further up
from that which you need to actually
speak to army elon about to get
neurolink which is
what were the things that arose in
consciousness but didn't make it to your
thumbs
yeah right because there's a bunch of
things that you could have said that
this note this note this note that no
still no i wrote it but no and then this
is the one that i end up pressing send
on yeah which when you think about it
how on earth we actually do have these
rapid conversations that are moving at
such a pace
it's quite amazing
yeah so i mean i don't know you know
what's going on what's going on upstream
because my you know again my field is
dedicated to what some colleagues have
called the rich surface of interaction
so
i don't know what's going on in your
under your school you don't know what's
going on under my school we've only got
what each other says and does as
evidence of anything so
that's that's where
conversation analysis focuses which is
different i i'm a psychologist by
background but i'm not interested
i mean i am interested as an ordinary
human being but i don't try to ascribe
what someone really thought or whether
they really are this thing because what
i'm looking at is how people are
attending to
am i coming off this way or not oh i
didn't want to come off this way i need
to attend to the way i'm coming across
or if people say things like i don't
know is that i'm not interested in
whether they really know or not some
somewhere in their brain and how you get
to that it's more like why is someone
saying i don't know at this point is it
actually to try and avoid answering the
question is it
is it to account for not being able to
answer a question what is that doing
right now because when you again when
you look at these words and how they're
placed in sequences like this it's quite
hard to just track them all back to some
sense of what's going on cognitively
because you can see that people are
doing
doing things that it's not just about
my brain to your brain it's also about
how am i coming across and and fixing
this and am i saying things that make
sense do i need to
keep tweaking and
keep kind of
turning the spanner a little bit until
i've got the thing
and we have sort of
we have shared
understanding of this thing that we're
both doing together in this interaction
also there's certain people whose
personalities don't lend themselves to
taking that feedback particularly well
or at all and everyone's got that friend
that just continues to blow v8 and
they're just plugging away and plugging
away and sometimes they're useful if
you're out on a a night out or whatever
and you just wants someone it's like
background it's wittering you know it's
just the birds outside you go yeah yeah
there goes bruce he's just continuing to
turn on and on and on and then you have
other people who are uh overly receptive
right to the awkwardness to potential
silences to whatever um you studied
american thinking that you looked at
hostage negotiations and suicide
hotlines and stuff like that as well
what do you learn from yeah
well first of all you know it's it's an
amazing job that the crisis negotiators
do so i i looked particularly at suicide
crisis negotiation so these are the
recordings so so i was given access to
the recordings
by the police negotiators who record at
the scene
as part of the job so again the data are
kind of already there they're like found
materials because they're recorded
i'm not you know i'm not sure if anyone
really ever looks at them again but i
this is this was the job
and
you know the first time you start to
listen to these recordings you know very
typically it's someone who's
on a roof threatening to jump or
threatening to asphyxiate themselves to
do some serious harm to themselves
and obviously you know it's the most
difficult data that i've ever analyzed
and you also feel a real sense of
responsibility because at the end of the
research i'm going to go back to the
negotiators and tell them what what i
found
um and
not not not do training because i don't
like to think of it quite as training
but basically what i'm doing is showing
them what they're doing that really is
effective
and some and showing them the things or
hoping that they will see from the
the the clips that i will then choose to
sort of play
anonymized and play out for them hoping
that they will come to the conclusion
that that isn't an isn't an effective
strategy but mostly it's about
your colleague who is amazing at their
job or is very experienced what is it
that they're actually doing
because one of the things that i you
know as a total novice into this
environment hadn't realized at the start
was that a lot of these negotiations
have a successful outcome in that the
person comes down safely so i was went
into it thinking
you know
i had no idea what the statistics were
you would be listening to a ton of
people's last rights basically exactly
yeah and that isn't how it is
so
so then what i'm interested in is okay
along this two hour four hour and nine
hour negotiation what are the turning
points
so that
we can think about
what are the what are the negotiators
doing to get that person to let's say a
more physically safe space on the roof
so that they can really push the
negotiation so a lot of the first part
is how do we get someone from a
precarious very precarious situation
where they might fall even if they now
don't intend to
commit suicide to somewhere much more
physically stable so that we can then
really start to you know
support them
encourage them and so on so that was
that and and a couple of things that i
found that were very interesting me and
my colleague um ryan sickfield
we we looked at
basic requests for dialogue
so
any negotiation requires people to take
turns in
in conversation that's that's what it is
it's nothing else
you don't know anything about the person
typically so you've got no background
about that you might think you're
interested in a psychologist like you
you don't know about their suicidal
ideation you don't know about their
intent you don't know anything about
them they're a stranger so you can't
sort of assess their background and then
on the basis of that developer strategy
your strategy has to evolve
on the basis of the evidence of
everything they say
so what you want is to think right
everything they say is staying alive so
every time the person says something
they're choosing to stay alive and not
jump so that's good so how do we keep
them taking turns but also how do we
keep them taking turns that are positive
rather than negative and that's what we
were after and so one of the first jobs
is
the negotiator arrives on the scene you
have to expect resistance because if you
do something so
strong in a way or such as taking such a
strong stance that you're on a roof and
you're going to jump
it's not the case that the negotiator
comes and says i really want you to come
down buddy oh okay then
because people are in in that situation
are again surprisingly logical
very clued into how rational they appear
so they're not going to just change
their mind like that
there has to be a negotiation it's going
to take time it has to otherwise people
don't look you know if you take a stance
you don't just change your mind people
want to be seen as consistent so you see
that
so how do you get someone talking and
the very one of the very first things we
found was that negotiators will
typically say
can we talk about how you are
and in this one nice example that i've
got the negotiator says
can we talk about how you are and when
you just show that line
i then show that the next line is 0.7
seconds so you think okay that's not
going to be
i'm not going to start talking you're
going to see resistance
and people think that they they're going
to say i don't want to talk about how i
am they focus on they're not going to
want to talk about how they are to this
stranger but in fact what happens next
is that the person in crisis says no i
don't want to talk
so they don't attend to the how you are
they just like i don't want to talk this
thing this this particular thing that
you've asked me to do and then they put
the phone down in this case so that's
that's the but now the negotiators got
to try again so you just see these
little natural experiments in which the
negotiator can't give up they've got to
try again and in the trying again you
see what is it that's working
and what we found was that
dialogue proposals that are built from
the verb to talk get resistance
they get resistance like what's the
point in talking talking doesn't do
anything
and they actually orient this notion
that talking doesn't really do things
whereas when negotiators say something
like
i want to speak to you and let's sort
things out so speak gets traction it
doesn't get resistance people don't say
things like actions speak louder than
speak we don't have that in our idiom we
don't have the same sense that speaking
doesn't do anything can you can
you know what the walking dead speaks
exactly we don't we don't say it that
same way and and and so we found and
this is what generally my field is
thought of as qualitative research where
you look at you know
in a lot of detail at small number of
cases but because we were so surprised
by this we we went through encoded all
the data did some
statistical analysis as well and
basically found that yeah speak gets far
less resistance and
faster traction than asking to talk and
i suppose the nice coder to all of this
is that we then went back and showed
this to the negotiators in the uk
and they were able to sort of get start
that
start it faster it's also nice to show
people things that is already part of
somebody else's natural practice we're
not telling them to do something that's
weird or
not part of anybody's or experience and
what they were just kind of doing
naturally somehow but it also shows you
that
verbs make a difference so back to the
point earlier about being pushed and
pulled around by language we're not
really aware we also typically think
that this person's going to do it or not
it doesn't matter what word you say but
but frankly if you don't look at the
actual encounters you you do not you
can't say that you can't say that words
don't make a difference if you're not
prepared to actually study
those words in those real situations and
and so that's what we found
didn't you have another example
about
bathroom towels in hotels
yeah that well that was that was me
thinking about this idea of nudge
because of course you know it's a very
you know very
it's a popsicle kind of behavioral
science kind of concept it's not my type
of thing might be so my type of work but
i think it is interesting that in this
particular study i can't remember the
authors now but it was basically you
know people recycle more
um with with the wording of the sign in
one direction rather than another um i
can't remember what that is now even but
but really my point was let's look at
the language much more than the
sort of overall message
that it's pushing towards so one of them
was about i think it was something like
you know please recycle your towels
versus something like you know 55 of
people in this who said in this room
your room um recycled and there's
something like that the more
personalized message drawing on social
norms and there's all sorts of theory
you can put around that but but for me
what i'd be interested in is looking at
the way
we are pushed and pulled around by
language in a not malevolent way
sometimes it is malevolent but but
actually words make a difference so
asking someone to to speak rather than
talk is doing something it's it's sort
of tilting the the outcome in some way
i've also shown that if you ask someone
if they're willing to do something that
they previously resisted doing a bit
then they're more likely to say yes than
if you ask them if they're interested in
doing it or if they would like to do it
there's a bit of a caveat here which is
that willing is quite a heavy thing to
ask someone if they're willing to do it
so you don't say to your partner would
you be willing to put the bins out
because it kind of implies well what do
you mean willing like like that's quite
heavy but but but actually willing gets
these turnarounds in ways that don't
otherwise other verbs
don't get
so you can start to see that
words in turns make a difference to the
very next thing that happens
um so i i i mean that that isn't the
kind of thing that that nudge behavioral
scientists typically look at but i think
it's very interesting the sort of
natural way in which we are you know
shaped by language all the time so going
back to those how are yous and the this
this this recording of a conversation
where it's two women on the phone and
they go debbie shelley what do you what
do you you know what's going on and and
you can see that they're just
immediately not they're not they're
finding it impossible to resist the
the conflict straight away how do you
not do that it's very hard to
immediately not engage in the frame that
someone has set up so as soon as you
accept that you you realize god we you
know how do you not get involved in that
argument how do you resist that
you know whatever whatever it might be
yeah
i've got a friend alex ormozy and he did
a video not long ago talking about how
he always convinces his missus to go to
cheesecake factory uh and he frames the
question in the same way that he used to
do on sales calls and instead of asking
if she wants to go to cheesecake factory
or saying that he wants to go he says
would you be opposed to going to
cheesecake factory and obviously like
well i'm not opposed to going to
cheesecake factory i'd just rather go
somewhere else but that's pretty
effortful in terms of a response to go
to and if you've already got well i
i would like to go to cheesecake factory
and you are not opposed therefore if i
have a preference and you have no
preference well no i do have a
preference i just haven't had my turn to
say it yet and yeah yeah that was really
interesting another person i've had
chris voss on the show you may be
familiar with the ex-head negotiator of
the fbi's anti-terrorism unit uh and he
has this really cool idea around getting
her that's right
from hostages sorry from hostage takers
hostages can't say anything and
he was telling this story about um he
was coaching one of his guys
through a very long
uh hostage negotiation that was
happening maybe in the philippines or in
vietnam or something like that a decade
ago and this guy had had these people
for ages and they knew that
the statistics suggest that if it gets
past a particular amount of time that
people start being shot this is not good
and they were just not getting anywhere
and
chris said to his understudy you need to
get that's right from him today and
that's right is about still manning the
other person's position it's about
showing them that you understand
precisely why they feel the way that
they do so this guy went through a huge
big long
spiel of
i understand that you feel like these
imperial colonialist powers have come
back and they've taken your country's
sovereignty and that you're holding
these tourists i know that you feel this
and i know that that's
this big sort of long
very sort of um protracted diatribe
about how this is how you feel and blah
blah blah blah blah
is that right
and he got a that's right from him and
then within 24 hours this guy had
released all of the different hostages
but he fled so they never ended up
catching this dude and then apparently
about a month later the hostage
negotiator chris is understood he
received a phone call from a completely
anonymous number
and he said i just wanted to let you
know
that if you hadn't spoken to me that day
every single one of those hostages would
have been killed i'm not sure what you
did but your bosses need to be very
thankful for you for having done it
however if i ever see you on the street
i'm going to kill you in cold blood and
i was like oh my god
it's such an intense story um but yeah
the idea around
somebody that maybe feels
mistreated misunderstood maligned
whatever it might be
showing them that you appreciate the
position that they're coming from
it seems to be a powerful tool
yeah i suppose we call it empathy and
it's really hard to get right because of
course the risk of telling people or
saying you know blah blah blah is that
right if you don't get it right and
you're no idiot everyone's dead now
exactly so this is why you know you have
to really
what i've seen in in those suicide
negotiations is that there is a point
where the negotiator has sort of built
up or at least they sort of show this by
what they do they've built up enough
evidence data from what's been said so
far to be able to do that kind of thing
at the right point in time and how much
they misfire if they come too early
and no that's not how i feel and and
then you're just sort of down the spiral
so so yeah um the other thing that i i
particularly noticed in the negotiations
but i've seen this in in other
situations as well any any place where
people start from quite different
stances so
do you want to do this thing i don't
want to do this thing or i didn't even
ask you to ask me about this thing so
you know a sale a sales call is is
another example but a crisis negotiation
is another and
anybody who's being tried you know
you're trying to get someone to do the
thing that they've actively resisted
and it's about claiming independence so
again the negotiators that were really
effective
weren't doing things like i really care
about you i really understand because
it's you can almost write the script
you'll be like well you don't know me
you don't care about me you don't you
don't know me you can't say these things
whereas the negotiators that were
getting the
outcomes sort of more swiftly with less
friction were saying things like how did
you get up there
because if you say how did you get up
there it's it's a question that is
answering it doesn't require any kind of
compromise because the person already
decided to do that
so they're they're talking about things
that they have already decided to do and
so the sort of interactional foundations
of the person coming down and that safe
outcome is switching from
if you like textbooks showing
care and empathy and help and
sort of more softly softly to actually
moving towards something that is a bit
more
direct like speak is it doesn't sound as
friendly as torque but it's actually
what happens better um we also see that
they if they offer to help that gets
resistance like you can't help me
whereas if they say something like let's
see if we can sort things out that gets
more traction because it's about action
it's not about the soft things that you
might imagine are working and then
eventually what you see is again
get the person in crisis to start
talking about things they already
decided to do today
and and get them talking about them
deciding to do things and that seems to
be the start of the successful outcome
of the interaction chris has another one
where he says a lot of the time in
relationships if you feel like there's
something that's off with your partner
people's go-to is what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong and his advice
a better approach
he suggests is to say it seems like
there's something on your mind
and
that again is
it's so interesting your work i mean you
must find it incredibly fascinating
because it's at the intersection of a
bunch of different things it's not just
linguistics it's not just what the words
mean
it's
culturally how is this word
in the milieu
beyond the definition of the word then
how's it been delivered then how long's
the weight been then what's the
particular stage of relationship that
you have between what are you coming in
with your priors what are the
expectations
yeah i mean it's a very multifaceted
thing and then to take that down and put
it onto a piece of paper and then then
to reverse engineer that back around
it seems pretty complex it seems like an
incredibly complex uh
science art form
i mean it is complicated but in a way
it's
what i'm doing is
is
explaining and showing people things
that people often know often because i'm
working not just on dating but you know
the more sort of serious and
institutional kinds of environments that
i've mentioned
showing people things that they're not
aware that they're doing
and how sometimes they're doing it
incredibly well and sometimes people
like them you know i are doing this
thing not so well at all and it's a bit
like proofreading you know you can't
proofread yourself but as soon as you
give it to somebody else and look over
their shoulder you can see all your all
the errors
and
and so
it is it is complex but
it's not like there's a huge conceptual
gap between what i'm doing and the
phenomenon it's not like i'm studying
black holes where like they don't exist
for people to understand them they
whereas
language communication exists for people
to live life and get everything done
and sometimes it can be a challenge
because we've all got our lifetimes
experience and anecdata of how we talk
but what i do know as an as a
conversation analyst is that how we
think we talk isn't quite how we talk
and sometimes the things that we think
are effective aren't quite right or we
can get a sense that that conversation
didn't go very well but
i can show you how exactly where and
then the challenge is to show that it's
not just a one-off it's a systematic
thing that people tend to do it this way
and it tends to immediately derail
create a friction create something
you're going to fix and you might get
back on track but you might not at the
end of that that conversation
have you looked at how easy it is for
people to change their
patterns the speed part speech patterns
and the sort of words that they use and
things like that
so i do a lot of training with the
research findings um so some and some of
those findings are easier for people to
see their way to doing than others um so
talk and speak
and
help and sort those words that
negotiators use typically at the start
can can be
changed if you like people can start
with you know
i want to speak to you and get things
sorted out rather than i'm just here to
talk and try to help and you can change
that fairly easily simply because they
typically happen at the start of the
encounter where it is the negotiator
doing the talking heavily scripted
and you haven't got into the kind of
back forth back forth at this point
so
so there is that on the one hand then
there are other there are other things
that you again are
easier to for people to change when they
are let's say delivering a package of
information that you can see
works really well or doesn't go down so
well so one of the very first things
that i did when i was sort of going from
oh this is interesting from a research
point of view to maybe the people who
i'm studying would also find this useful
was looking at mediators so people who
are trying to help
conflict without the courts involved
how do they have that initial
conversation with people who might
become their client at the end of this
conversation yes or no
how did they describe what mediation is
because hardly anyone's heard of it they
typically phone a mediation service
because they've got a problem they've
got a neighbor dispute or workplace
dispute but they don't really want to
ever see this person again in fact what
they're phoning for is you know they
start things like
i've just phoned a lawyer and they've
given me your number or i've just phoned
the police and they've put me on to you
or i've just phoned the council and so
this person wants their neighbor evicted
arrested you know whatever so then a
mediator is going to explain mediation
which is you know we're going to get you
together in a room and it's all going to
be fine
it's not a very easy sales pitch
but at some point in this conversation
there's going to be a moment where the
mediator will have heard the problem and
then say something like so let me tell
you a bit about mediation and then they
deliver a package of information about
what mediation is and at this point you
see the the outcome start to split
so these are the things that you can
train people to do because no one's born
knowing how to explain mediation and
what i found was that if you explain it
as a sort of ethos a philosophy we're
impartial we don't take someone's side
we don't judge
people are quite turned off by that but
if you explain there's a process this
happens and then this happens and this
happens then people are more bought into
the idea that things are going to change
because you've laid out a process and i
can see myself slotting into that
process so those are the kinds of things
that you can
you can change because
you just train your staff to explain
what it is your organization does in a
different way
i suppose i would just say though that
um
everything that i learned that is
effective is based in what someone is
doing
and a lot of people aren't doing it and
whether or not you can really train
people to
to to change their words in a moment by
moment where i'm not really sure
um
at the end of the day you need to be as
good as that that receptionist who or
you know who can hear
this person wants to talk about their
pet i'll go with that because that's
going to get me where i want to go which
is get the client whereas this one they
just want the information so i'll give
them the information and then they might
become the client that way and it's
being able to do that and so we have to
ask ourselves can i do that
can i tell the difference between the
one who wants to talk about the dog and
the one who doesn't not everyone can
elizabeth stoko ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out more of the
stuff that you do online and follow you
where should they go
twitter probably um i'm at listdoco on
twitter amazing liz i appreciate you
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace